dr anthony fauci causing more
controversy as he is being accused of
profiting off the pandemic by putting
out a new book
that was written during the health
crisis and newly released emails now
show
that between fauci and a researcher tied
to the wuhan lab they reveal that fauci
may have
given china a free pass early on that
researcher
writing this i just wanted to say a
personal thank you on
behalf of our staff and collaborators
for publicly standing up
and stating that the scientific evidence
supports a natural origin for covid19
from a bat to human spillover not a lab
release from the wuhan
institute of virology i don't know greg
my first question is why
would dr falchi have been communicating
directly with a researcher
from the wuhan lab and did he take
that researcher at his word i suppose
that and i think that researcher i
fact checked me on this somebody over
there who are you talking to
just anybody but wasn't this is this a
dude
he's was really involved in this and
this stuff
and he was on the board of like fact
checking on facebook so
he was like he was he had his finger and
everything by the way the book title
is uh fouchy's book title is expect the
unexpected 10 lessons in truth service
and the way forward
that was the second choice because how i
saved the world was taken
what i really noticed in the emails was
how many there were so many
kiss ass emails by people in the media
and other industries
trying to ingratiate themselves to pope
fauci
and it was so there was so much fawning
that i think i got a deer tick
just reading them but i think i i
there's a
he's all over the place he's very
careful he's very cagey because he knows
that his emails are going to be red
but this is this is kind of scary
because
basically they're massaging this idea
away
they're trying to make it go away to
greg's point about the praise
jesse that particular email went on to
stay from my perspective your comments
are brave the researchers said to fauci
and coming from your trusted voice will
help dispel the myths
being spun around the viruses origins
vouchers about to get the avenatti
treatment you know
love you one minute and then the next
minute they're like who are you
because he's no longer going to be
useful this is a long list of dirty
laundry from fauci
there's emails in there of scientists
saying yeah this
virus looks like it's engineered you
might want to look into it
one scientist emailed hey this is how
they engineered it yeah
voucher's in there sending emails you
know masks don't really work
and then he's out there on tv saying
people need to double mask
this is bad stuff and i think biden's
gonna soon look to get
dr anthony fauci a little bit of an
off-ramp because
next senate hearing i see rand paul
licking his chops
he's going to tear the doctor a new one
and it's not going to be pretty
harold jesse is referencing the one
expert who warned fouchy in january 2020
that the coronavirus potentially looked
engineered and had some unusual
features so to greg's point about this
book that fauchy is writing about the
truth
will he reveal that he was given a heads
up to look into that at the very least
we'll see look i think if you pull back
the covers on emails and a lot of things
i think you'll find a lot of back and
forth between people and government it's
hard for me
to reach a conclusion that dr fauci is
anything other than
maybe politically naive to call him
intentionally malicious or un-american
from a guy who's given his entire public
life from aids to covet
40 years has he made some mistakes sure
i think when president trump
i think maybe naively suggested that
maybe we could inject ourselves with
soap and that might serve as a defense
to covet and he asked doctor
say that harold well no he he asked dr
burks the question no it's about light
it was about infrared light
no but he also asked about well whatever
it was i thought it was it was an
interesting question and she answered
that do i have one of those so
all i'm saying is i think that i think
we have to you have to be willing to
move
beyond that and if we find that there's
an effort by dr
fauci to have covered up the fact that
this came from this lab and we're now
going to investigate it
um then i think the the daggers should
be out but it's just hard for me to
reach a conclusion
uh that i mean i don't think president
reagan wanted anything but freedom for
our country even though the iran contra
thing happened on his watch
people make mistakes they say things and
they move on this is not even close to
iran contra
but we'll learn from this book and we'll
learn more if we allow an investigation
i hope my party and i hope republicans
allow for an investigation
to take place in congress so we can get
to the bottom of whether this came from
now but how many people died in iran
contra compared to a pandemic
well more people died during this
pandemic than iran contract right if it
looks like you're not blaming it
for china if if you can point back to
that money that went to wuhan
to do gain a function and him trying to
cover that up
after 3.5 million people have died so
they could keep the heat on trump
instead of china and then lock every
american down so the democrats can
rewrite all these state election laws to
beat trump
no that's a pretty big scandal but i i
accept that but do you tell i want to
understand what you're saying you're
saying if we had
determined at the beginning that this
came from the lab as opposed to
manufacturing because this would have
united the country against
china instead of divided the country
against trump
let me get degan in here because
harold's making the point about public
service dr fauci 40 plus years but he's
writing a book and he's profiting
off of that book a book that he chose to
write during the pandemic
while this health crisis was still
happening
imagine writing a book during a pandemic
i mean who has the time
yeah at least he waited a little bit
longer than killer cuomo
here in new york um he's a spotlight
seeking hack
and we've seen that repeatedly over and
over again he changes his story still
gets booked on
cnn listen the last two books i read
were about ted bundy and diane downs who
tried to murder her three kids killing
one of them
so you know reading fouchy's book isn't
out of the question for me
the issue is money it is always
following the money and fauci's
national institute of allergy and
infectious diseases
funneled money through that researcher
peter daysex
eco health alliance into the wuhan lab
and fauci says definitively while it
didn't go to gain a function research
to potentially make the make of
coronavirus more transmissible
and more deadly he does not know that
there is no way for him to ever know
that but what i do know
is that money from the united states
could have gone to potentially
create a virus that has come back and
killed what six hundred thousand
americans
and three and a half million people
worldwide i kind of think that
is worth looking into and by the way
tony fauci he's passed his expiration
date but he's not naive
so if a explosion happens
in a town that has a munitions factory
you don't go look in the laundromat you
go
look in the munitions factory daily
caller had a tweet out today
sick of him yet it was every cover of
every magazine dr fauci has graced
during this crisis
one sitting by a pool as we know hey
sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else